when president biden test drove a new
electric vehicle from ford
he liked what he saw this sucker's quick
but the industry has a problem to solve
before consumers get on board with evs
charging experts say that concerns over
charging are holding many drivers back
from switching to evs
that's sending companies on a race to
improve the nation's charging network
it takes public fast charging to sell
cars people need the confidence to know
that they're going to be able to do that
but building this new fleet of chargers
won't be cheap
there's very much a chicken or the egg
problem because you'll put charges on
the ground but there's just not demand
here's how charging became the eevee
industries bottleneck and what some
companies are doing to try and fix it
charging is a surprisingly complex issue
for the ev industry
one of the main challenges is that in
many cases it takes too long to fill up
the battery of a car
the most satisfied ev owners according
to jd power
are able to charge at home overnight
that can be done with the regular plugs
in your home
but charging this way can take days to
fill up a standard range vehicle
the industry calls this level 1 charging
homeowners can upgrade to a level 2
charger but that can cost thousands of
dollars to install
in some cases then there are drivers who
can't charge at home at all
like many who live in apartments and
rely on publicly available chargers
the research says that this network
needs improvement
as of 2021 the us has roughly 41 000
of the faster level 2 stations available
to the public
the department of energy says that by
2030 the us will need
600 000 of these machines to meet
expected demand
private companies like revel are
stepping in to try and get ahead of
these issues
by installing even faster level 3
stations
this is rebel's first super hub in
brooklyn new york
it's stocked with a direct current power
station to service level 3 chargers
the industry calls these dc fast
chargers
paul sui the company's co-founder says
that this site
is the largest fast charging depot in
the americas
new york city has a major problem and
the problem is charging infrastructure
just simply does not
exist it is a challenge to find a studio
apartment in new york city
let alone a charging site where you're
talking about skyscraper levels of power
revel says that its fast charging plugs
can provide 100 miles of range
in about 20 minutes the company believes
that its fast chargers could ease the
anxiety of ev
ownership for city dwellers who
typically have to pay to enter a public
parking garage
before paying again for their charge
there's no paywall
you can access the charger for free
which is very unique in new york city
the second thing is it's just a massive
site we're talking 25 chargers in one
location
it's just a much better user experience
revel isn't the only company focused on
fast charging
dc fast stations are the quickest
growing segment of the ev charging
market
tesla pioneered this technology in the
2010s with its supercharger network
which has more than 25 000 stations
worldwide
but tesla's system doesn't work with
hardware from other manufacturers
and that represents another problem with
ev charging many of the systems on the
market
are incompatible in the u.s companies
are designing cars that use different
types of charging plugs which is
creating problems for people looking to
fill up
that's fairly different from the
customer experience at gas stations
in most cases the nozzle at the pump
will fit the car
that won't necessarily be the case for
evs
the industry is using a standard plug
shape for level 1
and level 2 chargers but there are three
different plug shapes in use
on the newer faster chargers experts say
that aside from tesla
companies are moving toward the combined
charging system or ccs
but for now drivers might need to carry
dongles to make sure that their car
works with the charging ports that they
can find
that's a problem that companies like
evgo want to solve
jonathan levy the company's chief
commercial officer says that their
technical team
is working to make their chargers
compatible with all evs on the market
we're currently in a process where we're
installing hundreds of integrated tesla
connectors at evgo fast chargers around
the country
because there are more than half the evs
being sold right now and while other
automakers are
bringing more models to market and will
continue to penetrate tesla drivers
and evs using chatimo and evs using ccs
all need access to charging the company
plans to have installed 600 tesla
connectors across its fleet
by the end of 2021 but in the race to
make these new
compatible fast charging machines the
costs for companies and consumers are
adding up
industry experts say that building out a
bigger and faster fleet of chargers
is going to cost a lot of money up front
before consumer demand picks up
researchers say that an installation of
a level 2 charger could cost tens of
thousands of dollars
but costs for the newer dc fast stations
could stretch into the millions of
dollars
to cover these costs evigo partnered
with a special purpose acquisition
company
to quickly raise funds but red tape is
slowing down the build out of its fleet
cities and counties have really been
hurt a lot on a budget basis across the
country especially in covid
and so if you have a part-time
permitting authority that can really
slow things down
when we think about how long it takes to
build a fast charging station
it's anywhere from six to 18 months with
exceptions on either side of that
and it could be a lot quicker if we were
able to again streamline some of this
and
work on getting the flywheel spinning in
this ecosystem
some lawmakers in washington believe
that the industry needs help
and answer your direct question we have
a deal a bipartisan group
including the president and many
senators are calling for 7.5 billion
dollars to build a network of chargers
along highways and in rural areas
but even if public funding materializes
the ev charging companies have to
navigate other bottlenecks
like regulatory approvals while the
development costs pile up
that could leave some eevee owners
searching for a place to plug in
for some time